Vsauce Kevin here in a building a
shelter expertly designed by humans for
humans to protect me a human from nature
so what is this doing here
more than half of you keep a nonhuman
creature in your house sometimes in your
bed people treat their pets like family
like babies why pets almost seemed like
a cuteness tax but our relationships
with them today and throughout history
can teach us a lot about who we are and
what we think it means to be human for
most of human existence we lived on
equal ground with animals what we now
call animism was the foundational
worldview held by our hunter-gatherer
ancestors the belief that non-human
entities including rivers plants and
animals all have a spirit or soul
hunting and killing animals for survival
involved elaborate rituals intended to
honor the spirits of the natural world
there's evidence of animism worldwide
from the Nazca P of Canada having strict
rules for consuming caribou to the
reindeer Hunter's of Siberia and various
bear cults including the Ainu of Japan
animals taken for survival were revered
while others were kept as pets and made
part of the family pets are so vital and
beloved that indigenous peoples from
Australia and Malaysia to South America
and Hawaii included them in one of the
most foundational bonds of human life by
breastfeeding baby animals
the awhat robe in the Amazon still do
the dawn of Agriculture and widespread
domestication of animals created a
distinction between man and beast after
about 190,000 years of relative parity
humans were now dominating nature in 350
BC Aristotle declared that Nature makes
nothing in vain and therefore everything
on earth had a purpose to serve humans
he also proposed skele not sure on the
ladder of life a hierarchy of living
things with human beings on top due to
their ability to reason a trait he
believed came not from the brain but
from the heart burrow man's dominance of
animals was entertainment the Colosseum
games routinely involved fights to the
death
with some species like the North African
elephant and European wild horse being
made extinct as a result animals were
put to work building and feeding growing
civilizations cats were self
domesticated during the rise of
Agriculture including themselves in the
human food chain by weeding out vermin
like grass people appreciated their
service and house cats were immortalized
in paintings during the Tang Dynasty in
the seventh century anthropocentrism or
the belief that humans are the most
significant creature was bolstered by
the earth being declared the center of
the entire universe questioning this
geocentric model and by proxy man
centrality in the cosmos was considered
blasphemy Galileo was found guilty of
heresy for supporting Copernicus's band
heliocentric model
in 1633 Galileo was imprisoned during
the Inquisition campaign in which Roman
Catholic orthodoxy was enforced by
persecuting heretics even pets weren't
safe they could be branded as familiars
or evil spirits that helped people
perform sorcery pets suspected of aiding
in magic tried and executed if found
guilty we went from suckling baby
animals and honoring beasts felled in
the hunt to publicly burning humans for
having pets England's witchcraft act of
1604 made it illegal to consult covenant
with entertain and froy feed or reward
any evil and wicked spirit - or for any
intent or purpose everything from dogs
and cats to rabbits toads and even ants
and cockroaches were suspected as
familiars that could lead to an alleged
witches death animals were tortured and
executed not only to mete out justice
but as part of public celebrations in
the great cat Massacre and other
episodes in French cultural history
historian Robert Darnton explains that
an aspect of the Carnival season of
celebration before Lent involved passing
around cats and ripping out their fur to
create a crude musical instrument of
tortured howls dancing around bonfires
was a joyous part of the summer solstice
fest
as was throwing magical objects into
them like cats tied up in sacks hung
from ropes or attached to stakes burning
dozens of cats in a basket was abolished
in Metzen 1765 so that's good the
context of treating animals like
inanimate objects can be found in the
philosophy of Rene Descartes who
believed in the superiority of the human
mind the father of modern Western
philosophy famously stated cogito ergo
soon I think therefore I am
but he considered animals to be like
clocks in 1648 he referred to beasts as
mechanical automotives filled with
organs that allow them to function but
are devoid of consciousness lacking a
soul that marked a departure from how we
thought about animals for centuries the
word animal comes from the Latin rune
animus which means soul it took the
advancement of science to return us to
our Radhika's that's Latin for roots the
Age of Reason brought with it a newfound
interest in Natural History which
included biology and zoology by the
1850s Alfred Russel Wallace and Charles
Darwin revolutionized how we think about
animals their theories of evolution
placed humans and creatures at equal
points of origin from which adaptations
for ecological survival arose over
millennia Darwin's catalyst for his
obsessive study of nature was his love
of dogs evidence of domesticated dogs as
beloved pets goes back to 12,000 BC with
a Natufian grave in Israel an old man
buried with a puppy recent DNA studies
suggest gray wolves and dogs share a
common prehistoric wolf ancestor that
went extinct between 9,000 and 34,000
years ago
wolves are the most successful adaptable
non-human predator in the world
they're now outnumbered 3,000 to one by
dogs because dogs partnered with humans
an advantage that anthropologist Pat
Shipman believes helped humans outlast
Neanderthals from Mesopotamia India
Egypt and Mesoamerica dogs were symbols
of loyalty and
onion ship and were buried with their
owners as guides to the afterlife
humans practice selective breeding with
dogs to encourage desirable physical
traits like size speed and fur length
but over the past 150 years dogs have
been bred to change their appearance and
highlight features we want to see like
shorter snouts larger eyes and floppy
ears neoteny is the detention of
juvenile features in an adult animal and
selective breeding by humans has
exaggerated these features and breeds
like pugs Bulldogs and the Cavalier King
Charles Spaniel in some cases it's
created unintended health problems
driving the Kennel Club's leading
geneticists
to believe that the less a dog looks
like a wolf the less it makes any sense
neoteny can also be seen in cartoon
characters with huge eyes and large
heads characteristics we think are cute
because the proportions are similar to
infants an actual cute character design
rule documented by former Disney
animator Preston Blair in his 1948 book
animation cuteness is based on the basic
proportions of a baby in 1971
evolutionary biologist and science
historian Stephen Jay Gould documented
the neoteny found in the evolution of
the world's most famous cartoon
character Mickey Mouse and just as
Mickey is a brand of Disney Pomeranians
are a brand of dog during an era in
which Gregor Mendel founded the study of
genetics through breeding experiments
with pea plants dogs were developed like
consumer products with specific
beneficial traits purebred dogs were a
common marker of status from Pekinese in
7th century China to Queen Victoria's
Pomeranians but a rising middle class
assured in demand for pure brands the
Victorian dog fancy and an industry of
breeding to meet that demand all of the
Labradors in the world came from a small
group of families in the British
aristocracy there's actually a
leather-bound stud book kept in a safe
in Scotland that traces the exact
origins of the Labrador details the
quest to influence the length of the
Labrador smuzzle the spacing of its ears
and the size of its eyes like a
hereditary recipe book to generate the
perfect lab
with morbid side notes of breeding
failures like put down useless the
oldest English book on dog varieties of
English dogs published in 1576 lists 16
different types today there are 340
unique breeds recognized by the FCI
but why dogs yes they've helped humans
hunt since before recorded time by
tracking and retrieving game guarding
mankind with their superior sense of
smell speed and hearing yes they have
expressive faces and complex
vocalizations that aid in our ability to
understand and communicate with them but
it may be a fundamentally human quality
that solidifies a relationship with dogs
dr. Julian Kaminsky describes pointing
as a triadic communication there's a
sender receiver and a shared concern
it's commonly used in language
development in infants the baby points
at an apple the parent tells them it's
an Apple the baby learns Apple Michael
Tomasello believes this act is a basic
building block of language called shared
intentionality and it isn't Universal in
the animal kingdom despite having
fingers and high-level cognition chimps
and gorillas don't understand pointing
because they don't believe anyone would
help them what if an infant's most basic
instincts is a willingness to trust its
parents and accept their help in 4th
century BC Plato argued that love forms
the bonds of human society by the 20th
century British psychologist John Bowlby
posited that infant social and emotional
development rested on the relationships
with caregivers and then a willingness
to form social bonds helped infants
secure their own survival satisfying the
foundational elements in Maslow's
hierarchy of needs there's a reason why
solitary confinement and exile are
amongst the greatest punishments for
those who break the social contract
often considered punishments greater
than
- attachment theory lays the groundwork
for the benefits of cooperation and
social exchange instructed at Aesop's
fables in 6th century BC the lion and
the mouse in which a mouse convinces a
lion to spare his life and to trust that
some day he can help him science is just
now catching up with a sum oxytocin is a
hormone that plays a role in social
bonding it's produced in mammals when
they care about someone and as
influences on trust empathy and
attachment it's released when humans
engage in positive interactions with one
another humans and pets release oxytocin
when petting plane were simply gazing
oxytocin was first discovered for its
role in regulating childbirth and
breastfeeding the facilitation and
nurturing of life itself studying
communication and relationships between
animals is teaching us about ourselves
Alex the African Grey parrot spent
thirty years being studied by animal
psychologist Irene Pepperberg Alex
proved that a large primate brain is not
a prerequisite for complex
problem-solving and language Alex can
recognize quantities up to six identify
50 different objects and had a
vocabulary of over 100 words at age 31
almost 30 years short of the average
life expectancy for a parrot
Alex suddenly passed away his final
words to Pepperberg were the same he
spoke to her every night
you be good see you tomorrow I love you
Alex gains celebrity status because he
expanded our understanding of animal
cognition but he also exposed our desire
to believe that devoid of the judgments
pressures and complications of human
existence pets love you for you the open
man and animal describes philosopher
Georg Hegel's concept of human as only
existing in the trance
sentence and transformation of its own
animality by separating ourselves from
nature we express what makes us uniquely
human but it's not easy to figure out
what that is our ever-changing
relationships with animals affect our
understanding of what they are but also
what we are in 1947 psychoanalyst Erich
Fromm wrote man is the only animal for
whom his own existence is a problem
which he has to solve by reconnecting us
with nature
pets help us navigate our existence
which means scrolling for cat memes is
actually a very serious existential
activity and as always thanks for
watching
the lion and the mouse a lion lay asleep
in the forest his great head resting on
his paws a timid little mouse came upon
him unexpected and in her fright and
haste to get away ran across the Lions
nose rouse from his nap the lion laid
his huge pall angrily on a tiny creature
to kill her spear me begged the poor
mouse please let me go and someday I
will surely repay you the lion was much
amused to think that a mouse could ever
help but he was generous and finally let
the mouse go some days later while
stalking his prey in the forest the lion
was caught in the toils of a hunter's
net unable to free himself he filled the
forest with his angry roaring the mouse
knew the voice and quickly found the
lion struggling in the net running to
one of the great ropes that bound him
she naught it until it parted and soon
the lion was free you laughed when I
said I would repay you said the mouse
now you can see that even a mouse can
help a lion a kindness is never wasted
that sounds true but is it yes it's true
I hope that's true a world of sad place
I don't know if it's true but a kindness
is never wasted even if never even ever
never seems to be is wasted never never
and still no never
it was wherever ever there's never why
hurry with that never wasted agree with
that never never
special thanks to my friends at the BBC
for providing awesome footage of dogs
cats and wolves check out their channels
for more videos and stuff okay thanks